hey
thank you
here
what's up
uh
[Music]
[Music]
two items for all of you at the top uh
today we released a report highlighting
the historic small business boom under
the biden harris administration last
year americans applied to start
5.4 million new businesses 20 more than
any year on record and small businesses
are creating more jobs than ever before
and it's been particularly strong for
entrepreneurs of color for example
hispanic entrepreneurs started new
businesses in 2021 at the fastest rate
in more than a decade 23 percent faster
than pre-pandemic levels
you heard the president say this today
but this approach is in stark contrast
to congressional republicans tax plan
which would raise taxes by an average of
almost 1200
on nearly half of small business owners
not only does president biden reject
congressional republicans plans to
increase taxes on half of small business
owners he also has an economic strategy
to keep the small business boom going
including expanding access to capital
making historic investments in technical
assistance programs to help
entrepreneurs identify resources
leveraging federal procurement to direct
hundreds of billions of dollars in
government contracts to small businesses
and leveling the playing field for small
business owners to reforming the tax
code also wanted to note that today the
food and drug administration announced
two proposed rules one to prohibit
menthol cigarettes and one to prohibit
flavor flavored cigars the rules
announced today would enforce
regulations related to what stores sell
and what companies manufacture and
distribute which is a critical
critical action to prevent children from
becoming the next generation of smokers
help adult smokers quit and
significantly reduce tobacco-related
health disparities with that why don't
you kick us off uh hello i have a few
questions about student loan forgiveness
first off is the president concluded
that he has the power to do this
unilaterally and secondly does he
believe that means testing his correct
approach
well uh there's been no conclusion of
any process internally yet but you heard
the president talk this morning about
his ongoing consideration of how to
provide additional relief to many
americans who are still uh still have
student loans even though they have not
paid a penny on federal student loans
since he took office um what was the
second part of your question how does he
decide to do means testing so he has
talked in the past about how um you know
he doesn't believe that um that
millionaires and billionaires obviously
should benefit or even people from the
highest income so that's certainly
something he would be looking at um so
just want to be very clear about the
power to do this he's looking at doing
this issue yeah but you're not saying
that he's going to send the bill to
congress or he's actually going to do it
well we definitely know he has the
ability and the the legal ability to
sign a bill congress passes so what
we're really talking about is
authorities through executive action
which we're continuing to look at and
he's continuing to consider and lastly
uh what concerns does he have with the
growing cost of college you know
obviously the cost of college has been
rising yeah very quickly uh this would
reduce uh borrowers out of pocket costs
to pay down some of their debt but what
about that cost of the education upfront
well
from the beginning of his administration
and i would say through the course of
his career he has expressed an interest
on the increasing cost of college and
the the barriers that that poses to
people getting a two-year or four-year
education um he has taken a number of
steps already since he took office to
bring down costs
for americans including bringing down
the cost of college the american rescue
plan provided nearly 40 billion dollars
in higher education relief for colleges
and universities much of west which was
earmarked for emergency financial aid to
help students to make college more
affordable for college and for current
and future students he also called for
in congress passed a 400 increase in the
maximum pell grant the largest increase
in over a decade and additionally we
have now approved the cancellation of
more than 18.5 billion dollars in
student loan debt for more than 750 000
borrowers so while he's continuing to
consider what executive actions he could
take using his own authority even though
if congress sent him a bill tomorrow he
could sign it and he would sign it to to
give ten thousand dollars of student
debt relief we've also he's not
hesitated and has also taken additional
steps and the final question uh response
to republicans like senator romney who
say this is a political giveaway uh to
consider canceling students
i would say um you know the president's
view is that uh as as the leader of the
country what he needs to do is continue
to provide relief to people who need it
most to help people uh get some extra
breathing room uh and that includes uh
getting people con this consideration of
getting people relief who have taken
steps to further their education and
maybe take steps to advance their their
family circumstances go ahead thanks
switching gears to title 42 the
president said today that the
administration would comply with
whatever the courts decide so just to be
clear there's not a plan to fight this
decision that would be a decision made
by the department of justice but they
haven't even done a formal uh ruling
that they're considering at this point
in time but there's the temporary
the tro so at this point
the administration doesn't have anything
to announce they verbally did the tro
they have not done i don't believe a
more formal written one that has been
looked at or considered by the
department of justice at this point in
time does the president disagree with
this ruling again it's a department of
justice to look at this the president
has talked about how he would the
authority is given to the cdc to make a
decision about when the conditions uh uh
exist to lift title 42 they made that
decision and he certainly supports that
and that's why we're preparing to lift
it um through the department of homeland
security and an interagency process if
the cdc determined like you just said
the order was no longer necessary then
it wouldn't make sense to fight to not
fight it to let it just stand well the
department of justice would make that
decision there hasn't even been a formal
issuing by the court it's been a verbal
report they said they would need to look
at that um they would make any
announcement about
i just any legal
to we just continue to hear these uh
democratic senators uh that were briefed
this week uh corto masto was the latest
she was briefed by the administration
and said that even though you've been
saying there's this comprehensive plan
to deal with the border after title 42
is lifted she has not seen a
comprehensive plan she said she did not
hear a comprehensive plan on how they
are going to address the surge or the
resources needed to make sure we are
addressing the drug trafficking across
the border so your response to her and
just big picture why democrats aren't
united on this
i can't speak for all democrats i can
tell you that we share the frustration
about how broken our immigration system
is and how there need to be fixes at the
border whether that is smarter security
funding or fixing the asylum processing
system that's long been broken and we
would welcome the interest of any
democrat or republican to work with us
on that effort and talk about and work
for it work on moving forward the bill
the president proposed on his first day
in office secretary mayorkas who
oversees this of course has been
testifying i think he has four he's
specifying to four committees including
the house judiciary committee uh today
um and he
laid out six pillars of our plan
including components that address
exactly those specific pieces how we
would surge resources personnel
transportation medical support how we're
enhancing cbp processing how we're
administrating administering
consequences for unlawful entry how
we're bolstering the capacity of
non-governmental organizations what
we're doing to target and disrupt the
transnational criminal organizations and
how we're going to deter a regular
migration but this is not an immigration
policy this is how we're implementing
the lifting of title 42. so we need a
longer term more comprehensive
immigration reform policy and we would
welcome any efforts to work with that
with members of congress go ahead hey
the request for 33 billion dollars how
quickly do you expect it will move
through congress and when is the
deadline for when you absolutely need it
i'm not here to set new deadlines um but
i can tell you that uh both needs are
urgent well i would say that need is
urgent as is the need for covet funding
is urgent um in terms of where we are
with um with spending just to give you a
sense of um
of uh the money that we've already we've
already allocated or already been giving
putting on the ground to the ukrainians
in the form of military assistance i
stumbled through that a little bit
as you know we had 3.5 billion dollars
in military security assistance we have
about 250 million of that left in
drawdown so obviously we will work to
expedite that and provide that to the
ukrainians but
in order to continue to help assist them
help make sure they have the
weapons they need the artillery they
need the equipment they need it is
certainly urgent to move forward on this
funding what is your view on why the
economy shrunk 1.4 during the first
quarter
so
um gdp which is what that's a measure of
measures a couple of different uh
components of economic data consumption
investment uh inventory and exports on a
number of these uh
these uh data components um we had very
positive signs in the same set of data
including uh consumption consumer
spending was up by about 2.5 percent on
investment business investment
residential investment both up as well
and on exports the number was down but
that is largely because our economy is
doing better than many economies around
the world so while we were purchasing a
lot of goods from other countries there
wasn't the same capacity to purchase our
goods that that is uh that is why that
number was was lower and then on
inventory which is another piece of data
that is measured um
quarter four of last year had the
largest inventory number of any quarter
in history in large part because as the
supply chain uh problems were being
fixed thanks in large part to the
president's efforts uh businesses were
able to get goods and they made enormous
purchases largest numbers to stock their
inventory of any quarter in history and
this what this data is is measuring is
changes in growth from quarter to
quarter so because of that even though
this was the fifth largest inventory
quarter in history in comparison with
the fourth quarter of last year um it
showed a decrease which led to the uh
two to the number but what what
economists um many economists jason
furman has spoken to this and others
what they look at as measures uh
the strength of the economy and what
they're monitoring closely from quarter
to quarter as important indicators are
consumer spending business investment
residential investment all of these
increased
at strong rates in the first quarter and
as as the overall demand and are good
signs for the strength of the economy
lastly
to what extent are you looking at
cutting tariffs on chinese goods as a
way to ease inflation well there's an
ongoing review of that uh led by
ambassador tai at ustr and we are
certainly continuing to look at where
these tariffs put in place by the prior
administration don't make sense and one
of the factors that we're looking at as
a part of this review
is certainly the impact on jobs and
wages and of course on inflation but
we're also looking at um and costs of
course of goods but we're also looking
at where we have concerns about the
economic policies and approaches of
china but i don't have any uh thing to
preview at this point in terms of how
that review is going go ahead just one
clarification does the president want
this funding for ukraine tied to the
covet 19 funding
uh we're not making a predetermination
of that from here we put forward both of
these uh funding uh requests today
because they're both vital they're both
important we need them uh both to help
the ukrainians and to help ensure we're
continuing our coveted programs here in
this country and around the world but
we're not going to predetermine for
congress how they move forward there's
just an urgency in moving them forward
it was just confusing because in his
letter to congress he seemed to say he
did want tied to the coven 19 funding
but he told reporters he didn't care if
it was tied to the covenant that was not
the intention of how it was written it
was intended just to convey we're moving
we're putting these both forward today
saying that it should be tied to the
covet 19 funding no we're saying these
are both urgent uh we would like to move
these forward we'll work with you to
determine how to get that done okay and
you said you don't want to put a
deadline on when congress needs to pass
and authorize this 33 billion dollar
request that the president has made but
how many more weeks can ukraine go based
on what they have so far and based on
the drawdown authority that the
president still has before you do start
to see interruptions in military aid and
economic assistance and humanitarian aid
well i would say because we have 250
million dollars left very much compared
to what you're at i know i'm getting i'm
getting to your point i'm getting to the
point here um you know there's obviously
more that's needed and we want to be
able to continue to provide a range of
security and military assistance to the
ukrainians now we strategically front
loaded the military and security
assistance we were providing a couple of
weeks ago expedited the delivery of it
because we knew that as russia was
repositioning in the east and really
re
changing their strategic approach to
focus on the donbass they would need
that on the front end so it doesn't mean
that it will be exactly the same pace in
every week but certainly there is an
urgency to getting this funding done
there has been bipartisan through
there's been bipartisan support in the
in the past and we're certainly looking
forward to working with them to get this
done as quickly as possible and it would
seem to suggest that there is a timeline
since
officials told reporters today bereaving
it that they believe this is enough for
ukraine for the next five months to last
at the end of the fiscal year
which of course
that would start in a few days if you're
judging well that's a different that's a
different question than a timeline for
getting the package done i mean we did
this on a fiscal year basis because that
seemed to make sense of course and also
because we wanted to do it over the long
term for planning purposes but it
doesn't mean that the funding would be
delivered tomorrow obviously we have to
get it through and move it through
congress and we want to do this quickly
as possible
good thanks jen a quick follow on
student loans today the president said
that he is not considering the 50 000
figure that some democrats have pushed
for
is there a range you can provide for
what he is considering is it more than
the 10 000 both of you have mentioned
before he has said that before so today
was not the first time he has said that
about fifty thousand dollars um in the
past i guess it's been a few months um i
don't have a top range for you i think
he was just uh reacting to that size of
the number uh he said in the past and
i've reiterated that he would be happy
to sign a piece of legislation or a bill
that came to his desk that canceled ten
thousand dollars in student loans could
be more than that we're looking at that
but i think fifty thousand dollars was
just his indication of that size and his
opposition to that
and then today when he was talking about
the supplemental budget he said that
um nato allies and eu partners are going
to pay their fair share of the costs as
well how does he define fair share
i think he was trying to send the
message which has already been underway
that we are going to continue to give a
range of and a significant arrange
amount of military and security
assistance but we other countries we
expect them to continue to step up as
well as this is going to be a sustained
effort a longer war as we've talked
about before
we're going to need other countries to
continue to provide a range of
assistance as well and we are far and
away the united states is the largest
provider of military humanitarian
economic assistance and other countries
have taken steps i mean germany just
announced uh this week right their their
plan or their intention and they may
have been delivered to provide tanks
something they have never done before a
number of other countries have announced
steps uh to provide a range of military
assistance and weapons that they've
never provided before but it was more
the president sending a message about
the need for every country to remain
committed to this sustained long-term
effort to support the ukrainians but but
he's not saying that they should be
paying
as much as the u.s in terms of a
monetary figure every country is going
to be able to provide different amounts
and different types of assistance so
it's not prejudging that
it's just an ask and a reminder and a
call to the world uh that we need to be
in this
for the long term and we all need to
continue to provide a range of
assistance one more on
yesterday i asked you about what his
brother said today he himself issued a
statement
um and he is asking why was i left
behind
he mentioned he's pleased trevor is home
with his family
but he is asking why hasn't more been
done to secure my release what is the
administration's response to paul
i would say that we will continue to do
everything possible to bring paul whelan
home we are in regular touch with his
family and his family members
and we don't outline in detail
everything we are doing publicly because
our objective is to ha return him home
with his family um the president is
focused on that um and we would say to
him uh we we are we are going to
continue to do everything possible to
bring you home
whether there has been any progress made
in the past
two three months
on their cases on whelan and brittany
greiner it wouldn't be constructive to
outline or detail any specifics from
here because our objective is to be
successful and talking about these cases
publicly and getting into specifics
often isn't constructive toward that
goal
jen thank you i want to start by asking
you a few questions about ukraine u.n
secretary general met with president
putin he's meeting with president
zielinski he's trying to strike a deal
to get those who are in the steel plant
out
ukrainian officials were very skeptical
of these talks heading into this week
does the administration feel as though
there's been any progress that has come
out of his talks with putin and
kenzalenski
look i would say that um it's not for us
to make a judgment from here we are here
to support
the efforts of the ukrainians and the
ukrainian leaders to
pursue diplomatic talks and diplomatic
engagements should they see that as
constructive we have not seen evidence
that president putin or the russians
have taken steps whether it is allowing
for humanitarian convoys to move forward
humanitarian assistance creating
corridors that would give an indication
of that but our objective is continue to
implement the strategy that we laid out
from early in this conflict which is to
provide the type of security and
military assistance to help the
ukrainians fight and win on the
battlefield they obviously did that in
kiev and pushing back the russians to
give them economic and humanitarian
assistance to strengthen their hand in
diplomatic talks
against the backdrop of the president's
announcement today in request for this
33 billion aid package can you say is it
the policy goal of the united states for
ukraine to defeat russia
well look it depends on how you we're
not going to define that from here
that's for the ukraine well that's for
the ukrainians to define um what we are
going to do from here is to continue to
provide them with a range of security
and military assistance as is evidenced
by the package that the president uh
proposed and put forward to capitol hill
today to strengthen their their hand in
the negotiating table and ensure that
they have the support and backing of the
united states in the world just to be
clear and i understand what you're
saying is for the ukrainians to define
but does the united states think that
success has to include russians
leaving all of the new portions of
ukraine that they've currently donated
again we're not going to define that
from here kristen there are a range of
uh of negotiations that may happen and
may take place and we're just not going
to get ahead of that ask you about
buildback better if i might or the
remains that built that yeah um
given that you are pushing for this new
aid given that you are pushing for
pandemic aid as well where does that
fall right now on the agenda is there
urgency to get those priorities passed
as well
absolutely i mean here's the thing about
congress and governing you you can and
you are able to do more than one thing
at one time right just even look at the
committees of jurisdiction in congress
the committees that are considering and
looking at um you know some of the
military assistance and security
packages may not be the same that are
considering and writing pieces of
legislation on a reconciliation package
there is a great deal of interest and
passion uh on capitol hill among
democrats and moving forward on
the president's agenda and the
president's proposal to lower the cost
of prescription drugs to lower the cost
of child care of health care of elder
care
and we're going to continue advocating
and fighting for that in order for it to
get done against the backdrop of this
election year do you need to have a deal
in place by memorial day that has
obviously been floated as a deadline i'm
not here to set new deadlines uh kristin
uh we know there is uh interest there's
passion there's advocacy we're
continuing to do a lot of work behind
the scenes um and we're going to
continue to fight to get it done you
don't want to talk about deadlines but
if you could give us a reality check the
president said today he's going to
announce something on student loans in
just a few weeks you had said that there
could potentially be an announcement
by august the end of the summer
realistically
can we expect to hear something from the
president in the next few weeks on this
stay tuned and we'll see obviously we
have to continue a policy process the
president will make a decision and once
we have a decision uh to make we'll of
course announce that what i was getting
at really is the end of august is also
the time that the student loan payment
deferral that's the kind of period that
it was extended through so it was more
about making a decision before then
we always like to beat timelines here
you know so go ahead thank you again
on student loan debt yeah the committee
for a responsible budget has spoken out
against this
saying they've done a calculation that
canceling ten thousand dollars per
borrower would cost 250 billion fifty
thousand per bar would cost 950 billion
what do you say to people in their camp
who are concerned that canceling student
debt can have an inflationary impact
well i haven't looked at all those
numbers and what incomes they would
apply to nor has there been a proposal
that the president has put out on this
front or anything that's passed through
congress but what i would say broadly
speaking is that when you look at the
choices that need to be made the
president is looking at the impact of
student loans something that many people
in this country millions of americans
undertook to to get a better education
to make sure they were advancing their
own knowledge to maybe help their family
have a better life uh that finding ways
to provide relief to students to make
sure that these working cl working
families are getting relief is more
important than tax cuts to millionaires
billionaires and corporations and we can
make choices about uh about where we
invest and where we think we can make
the tax system more fair but there isn't
even a bill that's moved through
congress nor have we put a proposal
together so i don't those numbers aren't
based on any reality at this moment
broadly speaking is there any concern
that you know given this narrative that
it could have an inflationary impact
it's coming from
critics of this administration we're
looking at the economy looking at
inflation and having problems with where
it stands is is there a concern that you
know canceling student debt could make
it hard for the joe manchins of congress
to sign on to
bills that would you know
pass
elements of buildback better that you
guys are still trying to get through
which he said he won't do because of
inflation well i'm not going to speak
obviously for senator manchin i haven't
heard him made that point in the past
either what i would say is that the way
that inflation impacts people across the
country is costs right costs to their
bank accounts cost of their budgets and
what we're talking about here is how to
provide people with relief uh how they
can how we can provide them with relief
or consider providing them with relief
so that they have more money to spend on
things in their lives and providing
student loan relief is exactly that and
the president has taken a range of steps
to address and lower costs for people uh
considering this is one of them
extending the pause on student loan
payments is one of them uh but also
fixing the the glitch the family glitch
and the affordable care act is another
one of them so when we talk about
inflation sometimes we talk about it
like you know a 50 000 foot ivory tower
economist might and really what in how
inflation impacts people is costs and
what they're paying out of their pockets
so actually considering this would be
helping americans address exactly that
issue and then on
this new report that the department of
homeland security is setting up a
disinformation governance board to
tackle misinformation ahead of the
midterms um secretary marcus
said that part of its um intention was
to tackle misinformation in hispanic
communities especially can you give us
an idea of what this board is going to
be doing what their authority would look
like
sure jack i really haven't dug into this
exactly i mean we of course support this
effort but let me see if i can get more
specifics we know that there has been a
range of disinfo out there about a range
of topics i mean including covid for
example and also elections and
eligibility but i will i will check and
see if there's more specifics there's
been some um criticism of the person
who's been chosen to oversee this board
she had previously called the hunter
biden laptop a trump campaign product um
seeming to discredit its validity or
validity of reporting surrounding that
um
how can can you assuage concerns of
people who are looking at this person
who's been pointed to this position and
wondering if she's going to be able to
accurately judge misinformation now that
a lot of that reporting has been
proven to be
factual in some ways well i don't have
any comments on the laptop but what i
can tell you is that it sounds like the
objective of the board is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities i'm not sure who opposes
that effort
and i don't know who this individual is
so i have no comment on it specifically
nina jankowicz she also just recently
made some polarizing comments about the
twitter elon musk's twitter purchase
it's just getting some pushback uh from
critics who are saying this person
may not be the right choice for a board
that is run by the department of
homeland security can you speak to that
at all i don't have any information
about this individual i i can check on
more information about the board go
ahead
how much of the original 13.6 billion
for ukraine has actually been spent at
this point reporters are still trying to
understand
the the answer to that well i noted a
little bit earlier i think in response
in in proactive preemptive response to
this question that of the 3.5 billion on
security we've spent
3.25 billion of that already which we
have transparently provided regular info
to all of you on in terms of the
humanitarian and economic assistance a
lot of it has been allocated to how it
would be spent i can see if we have an
update on what has actually gone to
ground
okay and secondly on the menthol ban um
some uh black community activists the
aclu members of the cdc
have
raised concerns that it could push more
of the illicit market which would lead
to racially profiling uh black smokers
can this administration assure that
won't happen
absolutely because this uh rule would go
after manufacturers and people who sell
not individuals who smoke menthol
cigarettes and it would save lives i'd
also note that the naacp put out a
statement saying for decades the tobacco
industry has been targeting african
americans and have contributed uh to the
skyrocketing rates of heart disease
stroke and cancer across our community
the tobacco industry is on a narrow
quest for profit and they have been
killing us along the way the naacp has
been calling for a ban on menthol
cigarettes and flavored e-cigarettes for
years now and we applaud the fda's plan
but what we're talking about here is
this these rules are estimated that it's
estimated that eliminating menthol and
tobacco products could prevent up to 650
4 000 deaths over the next 40 years and
up to 238
000 deaths of among african americans
but this is not about going after
individuals smoking menthol cigarettes
this is about manufacturers and people
who are selling them
better than that and believe pro-life
catholics among them should function
clinics that advise women
you're going to give these people five
and six questions i get one i think if
you could if you could sit here and be
respectful of your colleagues here that
might work better go ahead
sir sir okay i think he's the next
question go ahead
okay so i'm not gonna get an abortion on
an emblem
your
statement laid out a bunch of domestic
issues that would be discussed in
regional issues
like uh economic cooperation et cetera i
was wondering if the president was
planning to raise amlo's attitude
towards russia and ukraine he's been
really looked to criticize russia ideas
and really joined this international
effort so the president's plan to raise
that tomorrow you know it's it's a good
question the primary focus of the
meeting as you outlined is about kind of
getting ahead of the summit of the
americas talking about the agenda
obviously there's a lot to be discussed
as it relates to migration and this
meeting was planned in advance of our
long-term planning of the potential
lifting of title 42 as well
it is often on the president's mind as
you know russia and ukraine and the
conflict uh so while it may not be on
the preemptive agenda we will have a
more comprehensive readout once the
meeting is concluded gdp report i'm just
wondering if the contraction has the
white house rethinking its support for
the fed's plan to raise interest rates
uh we continue to support uh the uh
intention or stated intention of the
independent federal reserve to
recalibrate and we support that effort i
noted a lot of the different data
measurements here because i think it's
important to note that the inventory
piece was not unexpected i mean we
actually spoke to it a couple of days
ago as well given the record inventory
numbers from the fourth quarter of last
year and the fact that it measures the
comparison the change of growth from
quarter to quarter and then lastly um
this happened while you came out here so
you might not i've heard about it but
senator manchin said at a hearing that
he thinks the electric vehicle tax
credit quote makes no sense and i'm
wondering what your reaction to that is
and whether you think that further
complicates uh skinny reconciliation
bill getting courage uh i i would say
that senator manchin remains a friend of
the presidents and someone we will
continue to work with and look forward
to continuing engagements with go ahead
the military aide it seems like the
president said his quote basically run
out the military i'm sorry the
humanitarian and economic aid if it has
not yet run out could those funds be
diverted first from the white house to
additional security and military
assistance
is that something that you can do is it
something that you are considering i
don't believe it's a good question i
don't believe that's under consideration
in large part because the humanitarian
and economic assistance is vital think
about the number of the millions of
refugees the millions of people who have
been become homeless as a result of this
or no longer in their homes as a result
of this war um and there are a range of
economic needs that president zielinski
has spoken about himself about uh that
will be needed over the coming months so
that's why there are multiple buckets um
and that will continue to be the case
i'm not aware of any consideration of
reallocation of funds the other question
i was going to ask is in terms of having
the 250 military i'm sorry 250 million
dollars of military assistance that
remains um could you all essentially
spend money on the
front side in the coming weeks if
congress is unable to pass something
recoup it from the supplemental later
and if you do that is there a limit to
how much money you can spend that way
just so i understand i may have to ask
omb this question can we kind of
get a line of credit of sorts
okay um to to kind of purchase or things
along those lines let me check and see
uh with our budgetary experts no one
knows more than how this works than
shalonda young so i will check with her
and get back to you
is that the administration's policy to
continue to provide
essentially an unlimited amount of money
to ukraine is there a top-of-the-line
budget
is the thinking that
the administration will continue to
support ukraine for as long as it needs
how much money
well i think we did this five-month
request because we wanted to be able to
do longer-term planning and work with
the ukrainians our european partners
this is not all for ukraine it's also
for some of our eastern european
partners and others to help support them
uh during this time as well uh but i i'm
not gonna get ahead of where we will be
in three months four months five months
uh our objective is continue to support
the ukrainians but i i'm not going to
get ahead of where we are at this point
in time i can note and i know this goes
to alex's earlier question i mean a
little bit in terms of the other
components and i can see if there's more
of a specific of what's been spent down
but when it comes to humanitarian
economic food and other security
assistance some of that funding is you
know 1.7 billion to ensure continuity of
ukraine's democratic operations and
provide other macroeconomic assistance
hundreds of millions of dollars in food
shelter and other humanitarian aid to
ukrainians
but we can also see if there's more
specifics on where we are with the spend
out of it go ahead yeah uh revisiting
student loan debt and that issue
why isn't president biden willing to go
as high as 50 000
that's the figure that majority leader
chuck schumer's as has pointed to that's
the figure that a lot of progressive
democrats have pointed to so what about
that number gives the president concern
the president himself has spoken to this
in the past so i'd really point you to
his own words on this front but
i'm happy to get them to you after the
briefing but what i can tell you is that
the president has said many times that
he would be happy to sign a bill that
would provide ten thousand dollars in
relief to uh individuals who have
student loans and congress could send
him that that hasn't happened yet that
could be the first focus of congress as
an example and he's continuing to
consider what he has the executive
authority or authority to do uh with his
own uh power so i'm just not going to
get ahead of that consideration process
so go ahead
i mentioned the 33 billion dollar
package and how urgent it is we don't
yet really have a timeline on
how urgent you know if it's weeks or
months or
can you detail at all sort of the white
house strategy behind
getting that money secured the president
obviously next week is going to to
alabama to tour lockheed martin and yeah
the javelin see javelin
is being made
that may be one opportunity to draw
attention to this are there other things
that the white house is doing
strategically to to get that urgency
you know felt by members of congress
look i think you are going to see a full
court press from us on this funding as
well as the coveted funding which is
very
which is vital to the continuation of
our fight against the pandemic
and you will see that in the form of
engagement with members on the hill and
committees you will see that in the form
of our secretary of state our secretary
of defense and other national security
officials speaking publicly uh
testifying as many of them are and
speaking to it during testimony and
obviously you noted uh the president's
visit to the factory uh the lockheed
martin uh factory i believe in in
alabama next week even the decision
today for the president to make the
announcement himself instead of doing
just a background briefing and providing
all the details to all of you was an
effort to
talk through the vital need of this
assistance what it would go to and
elevate it to that level and then is
there any effort i guess
you heard this a little bit from him
today talking about how ukrainians are
giving up their lives so so the the
money
i guess is there anything that the white
house is doing to to address the concern
from some americans that this is an
awful lot of money going to a foreign
country when we have domestic needs at
home i don't know if there's anything
proactively that you guys may do to try
to make that case for why this amount of
money is needed well i would say that
you we've also seen an incredibly hard
uh heart uh felt outpouring of support
from the american people for
the efforts of the united states to lead
in standing up to russian aggression and
to stand up
in favor and support of the ukrainians
you know to the president this is about
american leadership in the world it's
also about standing up for democracy
versus autocracy it's about standing up
against uh one foreign country invading
another foreign country um and uh you
know it's about american leadership in
the world so we will continue to
articulate that and make that clear um
and that is part of the reason why the
president also detailed in specificity
today what all of this would go to i
mean some of it a great deal of it is of
course to military assistance to fight
this war but there is funding in there
as he noted this morning for uh food
security and ensuring that we are
addressing any food shortages around the
world there's assistance that is going
into humanitarian assistance and helping
the outflow of refugees and so it was
important to him personally to uh lay
out the specifics in his remarks this
morning so we got a really simple
question yes thanks ken looking ahead to
the president one question you give
these people six questions from the
front looking ahead to the presidential
trip to japan that was announced last
night i'm wondering if you can talk
about the quad summit yeah wondering if
you can talk about uh how the president
will raise sort of a unified response to
russia yeah india at the table and then
also uh sort of the china taiwan issue
uh well
on the japan on the first part on russia
um i would say first we've had a number
of engagements uh as you know with
leaders in india about uh our approach
to supporting the ukrainians um in this
in this war whether that is sanctions
and uh the enormous sanctions package
we're putting we've put in place or of
course the assistance we've provided we
will convey the same sentiment uh in
this meeting now this meeting is several
weeks away so a lot can certainly happen
and as you know other members of the
quad have also been vital partners and
uh vital um you know supporters of the
ukrainians effort to fight the war uh
including japan i mean japan just as an
example has not only provided a range of
assistance but they've also
agreed to divert some of the lng
resources to help europe so there's a
number of steps they have also taken
that will be a part of the discussion
and certainly the president will provide
an update on what we're doing and where
things stand at that point in time um
we're just not quite there on previewing
the agenda yet obviously the president's
position on taiwan has not uh changed he
will certainly restate it during this
meeting but i'm sure we'll have more to
preview as we get closer to the trip
how will that be raised as well again as
we get closer to the trip there's not a
change in our policy obviously the
president's policy is based on the
taiwan relations act um that will
continue and as we get closer to the
trip i'm sure we'll have more to preview
go ahead thanks john uh one question i'm
a little overwhelmed
um do you have any update any insight um
on the explosions in france and austria
uh earlier in the week yeah and if the
russians were to open
a new front in moldovan territory would
that trigger
any new consequences for russia
um on the first part i just don't have a
new confirmation or new details to read
out from here um we're still continuing
to
look at the explosions from earlier this
week
i'm just not going to get ahead of a
hypothetical at this point in time in
terms of what consequences there would
be uh yesterday we were talking about
how there's great access to peck slogan
in the country you're trying to get the
word out
on its effectiveness
one of the main issues with pax lopez is
that an individual who's eligible has to
test positive and then they have to race
to get it within three days even though
they're quarantining is there any
conversation within the administration
to change that for an eligible
individual to be able to get it
pre-emptively i think that would be a
decision likely made by our health and
medical experts so i just don't have
anything to preview at this point in
time it requires a prescription right
but there are a range of ways to have
those conversations with your doctor so
i'm not sure it always involves a race
to the doctor's office but different
doctors can have virtual appointments
and other means of getting prescriptions
it's about consulting to ensure you're
eligible
thank you jen um so i have a question on
ukraine and then i'll follow up on my
colleagues questions uh the lengthy's
top advisor tweeted today that ukraine
should decide whether to strike russian
military facilities i know you've spoken
to on this before but you're uh trying
to avoid a hypothetical situation but
this seems like it's getting closer
towards a non-hypothetical situation can
you
give you at least
outline i appreciated that okay go ahead
whether the administration believes that
this is aspiratory or uh could be
constructed well
you know one i think it's important to
take a step back and remember what we're
talking about here i mean it is russia
that started this war invaded ukraine
and violated ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity it's russian
forces that have committed war crimes
and horrifying atrocities and it's
russia that continues to attack
ukrainian targets in ukraine every day
so even if we are dare i say getting
into a hypothetical what we're talking
about here is not
any intention of
ukraine invading russia and trying to
take russian territory going after
russian civilians going after russians
hospitals we're talking about
consideration of military targets it's
something very different
so i just think that's important context
for everybody to consider ukraine there
is
no formal announcement as of uh right
now about jakarta inviting zelensky to
g20 but uh our sources suggest that they
are indeed inviting both zelensky as
well as putin so under those
circumstances would the president
consider attending i know it's still six
months away but uh under those
circumstances it remains the same well
we certainly welcomed reports about
ukraine's invitation obviously we can't
confirm that on behalf of indonesia who
is hosting and the president has been
clear about his view that shouldn't be
business as usual and that russia should
not be a part of this um but again it's
six months away we don't even have
confirmation of these reports so i i'm
certainly not going to get into a
hypothetical initiative yeah follow up
on on the issue of that you know
americans being concerned about the
amount of money being sent out to
ukraine uh one of the things that the
president outlined today in this speech
was not just humanitarian assistance but
also allow pensions and social support
to be paid to the ukrainian people so
what would you say to the american
public who says okay it's one thing to
help ukrainian refugees with food and
shelter but why should we be paying for
their pensions
well look i would say that we have
provided a range of economic assistance
because we know that their
economy has been devastated not of their
doing because they were invaded by a
foreign country and they're going on let
me finish and
they are going to need assistance in
order to recover we provide assistance
economic and humanitarian assistance to
a range of countries around the world
because that's part of american
leadership and so i would say that's the
reasoning for this assistance being
proposed in the package
on menthol going back to the opposition
in the black community uh congresswoman
wilson today
and she said um she's opposing it she
says the president not should not only
deal with menthol but ban all instead of
just menthol she feels that it will
cause a profiling issue and she also
says this is something that should not
be dealt with in the midterms because it
will split the black community what do
you say to that and are you talking to
federica wilson uh al sharpton and krump
and others about this very issue
well let me try to answer all your
questions there i'm sure you'll let me
know if i don't april of course um you
know this is a public health decision
made by the fda um and the objective of
it was not to address politics or
handle politics in one way or another
but to save lives and the studies
estimate that um with menthol cigarettes
if they're no longer available it could
prevent over 650 000 deaths
including 238 000 african americans
there are also high rates of use by
children and young adults
menthol also increases the appeal of
cigarettes makes them easier to use
especially for kids and what we have
seen as you know is decades of targeted
marketing activities at the african
american community to promote uh further
um
purchasing and in in many ways and for
many addiction to these cigarettes so uh
this is not but what i think is
important for everybody to know and
understand including opponents is this
is not targeting individuals this is not
to give anybody license to arrest
somebody who is smoking a cigarette a
menthol cigarette this is going after
the manufacturers of this it is going
after those who are selling because it
is it has we have seen
decades of marketing targeted activities
at exactly these communities
with that said as you say decades i mean
there's been efforts to stop the
targeting through billboards and urban
communities in the 90s and
this is decades old but why now you know
there's been progression but why now
instead of other issues well i i think
again this is a public health decision
that went through a public health
process it wasn't made through a
political prism or made
you know for any other reason than the
lives that it could save
good thank you jen um at least seven
uh sailors have died by suicide since
the uss george washington began
undergoing a typical overhaul there have
been three just within the last month
the navy today confirmed three from
prior years is the president aware of
these suicides does he have any response
to them and is the military doing enough
to make sure that it is promoting the
mental well-being of our service members
well well certainly the president is
regularly briefed and is aware um and uh
the service of men and women and that
the stress and the pressure on them is
something that is on his mind including
making sure we have the right um mental
health care um the right treatments uh
for any individual who may be uh
suffering from depression or anything
that might lead to uh suicide
in terms of an assessment of what the
steps they're taking or what they're
doing i'd really point you to the
department of defense who'd be better
versed to speak to the specifics and
then to follow up on a question from
yesterday about ukraine and terrorists
the president could today if he wanted
to by executive action undo these
trump-era tariffs on steel imports from
ukraine
is there any reason why he wouldn't do
that does it have anything to do with
pushback from unions
there's an ongoing consideration and
process of reviewing a range of steps we
can help we can take to provide relief
to the ukrainians a review of tariffs
but there's a range of factors and i
just don't have anything to preview uh
in that process at this point that is
something that he is considering there's
a range of options on the table
in the back thanks jim i wanted to ask
the house is out next week um
and usually that would be where an
appropriations bill would start given
that the president is saying that
funding is so urgent in addition to the
ukraine proposal how do you see this
playing out legislatively
in the quick that you need it to do
well this is something now that we've
put the proposal forward and put it
forward and sent it up to the hill a lot
of the work is happening behind the
scenes engagement with our legislative
team steve roshetti louisa terrell
and this team with leaders on the house
side the senate side to move it forward
as quickly as possible but in terms of
the legislative mechanics i'd really
point you to leaders on the hill for
specifics on that and one other question
on coded funding
the prime administration has been
i don't know reticent is the right word
to release spending that you've done on
covet test the rapid testing program
whether it's how much you spent per test
or overall is that information that
you're planning to make public or
planning to provide to the senate and
houses they consider
whether to provide more funding the
testing program in terms of people being
able to order free tests
what specifically do you think we
haven't provided the amounts that you
spent per test or overall per contract
i'm sure if members of congress or
committees are interested in information
we'll have those discussions with them
directly go ahead thank
first question is about the uh security
path between china and the solomon
islands
do you have any concerns that china is
taking advantage of what's going on in
the pacific because the us is so focused
on ukraine and russia
i know we have spoken to this a little
bit um in the past and expressed um some
concern um
at the time i'll have to talk to our
national security team and see if we
have any any updates on recent
developments
one more question about
foreign confirmed reports by some asian
media outlets that are saying that
president biden is going to announce
some kind of china strategy during his
trip to korea and japan uh again this
trip is weeks away which is a lifetime
for us so we're not quite there yet on
previewing uh specifics of the trip and
what it will entail i'll do the last one
then i gotta wrap it up
thank you minnesota department of human
rights found that the city of
minneapolis and the mpd uh engaged in a
pattern of practice of racial
discrimination um they're working on
some dissent decrees but we know that
can take some time is there anything
that the president can do moving forward
is
can we say that the door floyd justice
and policing act seems like it's shell
for now and has the president seen that
report what's his reaction
i don't have any direct reaction from
the president to that report i can
certainly check with him on that uh
we're still consid continuing to
consider a police reform executive order
as you know that's consideration is
underway it continues to be underway and
his president has every intention of
signing one um and of course we would of
course still love to have bipartisan
legislation passed through congress we
know the anniversary is coming up in
just a few weeks and certainly that's
something that remains on the
president's mind thank you everyone so
much